thousands of people are fleeing the
Sudanese Capital Khartoum during lulls
in fighting between the Army and the
rapid support forces of fourth seized
fire that was declared on Wednesday has
failed many people are taking risks by
leaving their homes some are heading
south towards gazeera State that's
believed to be relatively calm others
have traveled North from Khartoum to
River Nile state where no violence has
been reported or people are trying to
escape a sixth day of conflict gunfire
and explosions were heard in cartoon
with each side blaming the other for
violating the ceasefire the World Health
Organization says more than 300 people
have been killed and at least three
thousand wounded Egypt says 27 of its
soldiers captured by the rapid support
forces have been handed over to the
Egyptian embassy
has more on the stream of people leaving
the capital
this used to be one of the busiest
streets in Khartoum we can now see an
exodus of people leaving the north of
the city and heading south if the camera
could pan around you can see people
carrying their luggage heading south to
neighboring states that are much calmer
and safer
many people here are benefiting from
this truce to leave Khartoum however
many shops remain closed as you can see
perhaps the distrust in this truce is
the main reason why shops remain shut
there continues to be sporadic fighting
in umdurman the vicinity of the General
headquarters office and the airport as
you can see people are trying to leave
Khartoum the humanitarian situation is
deteriorating and there's a lack of
health facilities and shortage of Food
Supplies
let's go live now to have a Morgan in
cartoon Heather people trying to flee
the capital what kind of Journey are
they running into
things
while we've spoken to one of the people
who left cartoon on Wednesday and asked
them how their Journey was to get to
Jazeera State Which is less than 200
kilometers away from the capital
Khartoum and she said that it took her a
period of 12 hours to get from the
capital Khartoum to the capital of
Jazeera State a trip that normally takes
roughly about three hours on a normal
day even with traffic on the road it
took her 12 hours to get there but that
was not the only thing she said she
faced there were checkpoints on the road
uh to madani up until a place called
baguette that's just the last point
between Khartoum State and medani she
said that all of them were rapid support
forces which questioned them about who
they are ask them for their IDs and
where they were going to and the reasons
they were leaving so it's clear that it
is not an easy Journey because it takes
all those hours but that's not the only
challenge that people are facing she's
reported that she's still looting others
who spoke to say that they have been
assaulted that they've seen people
getting shot at in their cars as they
try to leave so it is a risk for many
people but that's the risk that they
were willing to take because of the
situation here on the ground in the
capital Khartoum many residential areas
say that it's they're now going into day
six without any running water and that
the situation is untenable that they
cannot live like this they don't know
how to cook they don't know how to carry
out their basic necessities without
water around in the house then there's
the issue of electricity as well the
lack of electricity is affecting a lot
of people and the lack of access to
medical facilities many hospitals have
shut down are gone out of operation
since the fighting started on Saturday
and for many people these reasons have
been enough for them to take the risk to
leave the capital and find safety
elsewhere
and and a big part as you said because
the Seas fires are not holding there's a
case of another day another failed
ceasefire
people did
yes people have no longer have hope when
it comes to the issues of ceasefires
they say that they're waiting for quiet
periods where they feel like they can
make it out of their homes and not to
stock up on basic necessities but to
leave the capital there's been intense
Heavy Artillery strikes around the
facility of the general command since
the early hours of of this morning until
just up to a few minutes ago the Army
released a statement saying that they
feel that they have assessed the
situation around the vicinity of the
Army Headquarters and that the
airstrikes or rather the heavy artillery
strikes coming from the rapid support
forces have reduced and so they feel
that they're targeting the correct
positions of the rapid support forces
but the commander of the rapid support
forces spoke to Al Jazeera a short while
ago and he said that they are
surrounding the general command that is
the scene of heavy fighting since the
very first day of the conflict between
the rapid support forces and the Army on
Saturday elsewhere in the cap in the
country there is also fighting in North
Darfur in the city of old fashioned they
are presentations ongoing between the
rapid support forces and the Army as
well as in the town of that's in North
Darfur North Korea in the southern part
of the country so it's clear that the
fighting is intensifying not just in the
capital but other parts of the country
as well
all right we'll leave it there thanks so
much
and do Antarctic is a cartoon resident
and an activist she joins us on Zoom
from cartoon good to have you with us
how disappointing was it for you that
yet another ceasefire has failed
um very disappointing but also at the
same time expected
um it's kind of like left left left left
something in people like yesterday we
went out with the neighborhood committee
resistance members and we did a
graffitio no war at the time at the same
time uh the ceasefire was declared but
we we've been laughing because now
people call the bombing and shooting
during the ceasefire is the sound of the
the ceasefire or the sound of the truth
and we've been texting each other like
do you hear the sound of the truth and
sometimes it's like really very loud so
it's sad that people start getting used
to the to the shooting and the bombing
sounds but it's not disappointing we've
been disappointed at this for four years
now and the actions that were taken by
the uh civilian forces the the political
forces
um about how to handle this world before
before it breaks it breaks out so it
when we when we spoke a couple of days
ago you were if I recall correctly you
were running low on supplies I think
you've got a pregnant sister at home
um tell us a little bit about what your
situation is like now
um left my Facebook to a few folks from
the neighborhood and we managed to
collect some um vegetables and just some
floor and rice and stuff from the
neighborhood just some vegetable
leftovers and some salad some some
tomatoes and stuff just to hold this for
like two or three days for now we've
been hearing that farmers because I live
in um in in East cartoon somewhere we
have so many farms but it's not the uh
the harvesting season yes so there's not
a lot of vegetables but the farmers say
that they will try to provide and we're
expecting to get some vegetables and
fruits within the next three days well
you've got still no electricity right so
I imagine refrigerating food stuff is
still a challenge
and it yeah so
um right now people are giving away uh
vegetables they have and sharing with
the neighborhood because there is no
Fiji so it's impossible to to keep to
keep and then of course people were
forced now to go on a vegetarian diet
because you cannot have beef or chicken
and without refrigerators so it's yeah
that's the situation right now and you
mentioned that you went out as an as an
act of protest to
participate in a graffiti event right
that must have been yes dangerous though
people are afraid to go out and try and
look for food let alone spray graffiti
um sometimes
um resistance and Revolution taught us
that resistance could be a fuel for us
to live uh be to live because right now
we have nothing to do we don't have
water and food we don't have nothing to
do about it we don't want to as
revolutionaries we don't want to just
die in our houses without doing anything
the international world and the world
and Sudanese also needs to know that
this war does not have anything to do
with people or the will of people of
Revolution and we still want the
civilian Road we're not uh silenced by
the sounds of uh of the shooting and
pumping we're not silenced by the
shooting by the sound of War we
experience many many wars during the
four past four years today actually in
the memory of the uh Ramadan 29 June
which was during June June 3rd 20
um 2019 the the sitting massacre in
cartoon by the military headquarters
today it's 40 years for the massacre
since the massacre and we had to to get
out because us who witnessed the
massacre needs to go out each year and
to let out this this trauma but but this
year it's even worse because we're
dealing with war so there's nothing to
do but resist
all right thank you so much for talking
to us start Tarik there